all right i am back for another video um
first of all i just want to thank you
guys all for 500 subscribers it's
honestly really amazing it means that i
am ever so close to one of my friends
finding out about this channel and
bullying the ever living out of me
and if and when that happens we'll see
if i have the balls to keep making
videos but until then i'm going to keep
doing this in secrecy and we'll see how
it goes for me
today's video is about load balancing
which is a topic that is near and dear
to my heart
the reason for this is that i've had
some trouble balancing my load in the
past you know gave it all too much to
one person and i should have just been
spreading it out you know so
obviously load balancing has its real
life applications too but uh let's go
ahead and talk about it and uh we'll
figure out how to best do it
alrighty let's get started so load
balancing what is it well basically in
any massively distributed system there
gets to be a point where you can't just
build better hardware and use that
instead because you just have so many
users and that's known as vertical
scaling instead you have to use an
alternative method of scaling out your
application which is basically just
adding more nodes to your system that's
called horizontal scaling we've seen
this so far with databases in terms of
both partitioning
to store more data as well as
replication in order to kind of increase
the throughput of your data by adding a
bunch of copies of it
that being said not only are databases
something that you can horizontally
scale but also your actual application
servers if you have a ton of users
they're just going to be hammering one
application server and it's not going to
be able to fulfill every request plus in
something known as the microservices
architecture where basically individual
teams in your company are building out
their own services you tend to just have
a bunch of different application servers
anyway kind of running their own
functions and you need something to go
ahead and properly route requests
anyways the point is that load balancing
is something that is going to take all
of your incoming requests and make sure
that amongst your horizontally scaled
application servers or even databases
they're not getting overwhelmed by them
so let's go ahead and talk about how
those actually work
basically as you can see here in the
following diagram you can have load
balancers sitting between a client
device such as a mobile phone or a
laptop and your application servers and
also between your application servers
and your database
okay so how does load balancing actually
work well it's something like this
basically every single you know unit of
time load balancers exchange heartbeats
with your application servers or maybe
even your databases to just get an idea
of how many open connections they have
if they're experiencing lower high load
the time of the last heartbeat you know
they're keeping track of this and some
sort of table on on disk probably and
then also this is done locally as
opposed to something like an external
coordination service because if this was
done an external coordination service
then you would have to go ahead and
query that every single time and if
you're hitting the load balancer every
single
request that you're making to your
servers that would be a huge performance
hit
additionally then you're going to kind
of take all these metrics and route
traffic to each server based on some
sort of routing policy which i'll
discuss now
so here's some possible uh basically
possible ways of going ahead and
deciding which server you're going to
send each request to
one of them is just lease connections
you just go ahead and look at which
servers have a bunch of open tcp
connections and you send them to ones
that don't
least response time the load balancer
can actually just go ahead and keep
track of the average amount of time it's
weighted for responses from each server
and then use that as kind of a heuristic
in order to decide which server is
actually going to be fastest or has the
least load currently on it
there's round robin which is basically
deciding and ordering of the application
servers and then making sure that each
request goes to every node in that order
once before restarting where you send
those requests to and then there's a
variation of that called weighted round
robin which is basically just taking
into consideration the actual computing
capacity of each server so you know if
one server is doubly you know more
computationally powerful than another
it'll probably see two requests um while
you know the the half is powerful server
sees one in one of those round robin
iterations and then there's also hashing
which is what we've discussed quite a
bit in the past with um partitioning and
that's basically where you take the
contents of the request and you go ahead
and send it to a given application
server so i'm going to expand on that
because i was kind of purposely vague
there
so what can you actually
hash on well there's this concept of
layer 4 versus layer 7 load balancing
where in layer 4 requests are routed
based on kind of the low level network
transport layer so that gives you things
like the ip address of both the source
and destination and also ports in the
header
since you have less information to
potentially consider unpack this is
going to be computationally faster it
requires less resources layer 7 on the
other hand actually lets you look in the
contents of the packet that you're
sending which means that requests are
going to be routed based on those this
provides you with more flexibility and
allows you to do kind of like smarter
routing which i'll discuss in a second
you can hash on more relevant
information
so this kind of comes into well what are
we doing as far as hashing goes are we
just using a modulus where we take you
know the hash of our request id for
example and then do the modulus of the
number of servers that there are well no
you probably shouldn't do that because
we have consistent hashing which i've
talked about in a previous video so
recall that consisting hashing is
basically just an algorithm that goes
ahead and distributes a bunch of items
into a variety of buckets and the reason
it's so useful is that when buckets are
added or removed
consistent hashing ensures that the
minimum number of items can be
distributed from each bucket or moved in
a manner that um you know there's very
little rebalancing so why is this useful
for load balancing well it's not
inherently the same thing as
partitioning right because in
partitioning if you rebalance all the
keys that's a ton of strain on the
network there's no extra strain on the
network to actually send requests to
different server nodes however
if you are utilizing local cache on each
server node
then being able to put similar requests
on the same server is super useful
because you might be able to cache
certain results such as images or
database calls or even the result of
certain computations and as a result of
that
you can greatly speed things up so
that's why it's important to use
consistent hashing in this case as
opposed to just any sort of normal
hashing algorithm with a
modulus
okay let's also talk about availability
so if you remember my diagram from
earlier in the video i kind of just
acted as if there was only one load
balancer and that's pretty naive if you
do that because it acts as a single
point of failure and in any systems
design interview if you see that there's
just you know one of something it's
probably a single point of failure and
you should probably talk about that
so obviously we need to figure out some
sort of
way of keeping things in check as i
mentioned earlier coordination services
are a little bit less feasible and
something like a load balancer simply
just because
it requires too many network calls i
suppose you could use a coordination
services
or a coordination service just between
multiple load balancers in order to
keep track of which ones are alive and
which ones aren't through heartbeats and
then you know promote a backup to be the
primary however generally speaking it
seems like there are two ways of people
doing high available led load balancing
and they're known as active active and
active passive
active active load balancing
is where you basically have multiple
load balancers running at once all
routing requests at the same time and
they kind of have to share the same
configuration state probably through
something like network attached storage
that basically means though however that
if both these guys are running it close
to full capacity if one of them goes
down that the the other load balancer
might be pretty overloaded
we also have this concept of active
passive where basically we have one
machine running as the only active load
balancer and then a second one just
sitting there sharing the same
configuration state and basically just
waiting sending heartbeats between the
other load balancer and it making sure
that the second load balancer
if it goes down that the passive one can
take over and you know i imagine that
there would be some sort of methodology
to kind of ensure against something like
split brain maybe by using like an epoch
number or a fencing token so they can
you know communicate with one another to
an extent
okay so in conclusion um you know
obviously there are pros and cons to
load balancing but the truth of the
matter is you're going to use a load
balancer any single time you have a good
amount of application servers it's kind
of a necessity
and as a result they you know are pretty
much in every single huge application
and scale and oftentimes they even
perform more than just load balancing
sometimes they act as a reverse proxy
which basically means they're the only
public-facing part of your application
that users can access over the internet
and then everything else is kind of
in private behind a firewall and all of
your servers can only talk to one
another and then the load balancer is
kind of like the the gateway to all of
that
additionally sometimes they do things
like encryption slash decryption of you
know request to make sure the data can't
just be you know stolen or something or
snooped and then
in terms of just the general pros and
cons of load balancing obviously the
biggest pros are that
it makes sure that your servers don't
get overwhelmed as well as maximizing
local cache performance via that
consistent hashing you just want to be
able to send the same request to the
same servers in order to cache as much
as possible
where the biggest cons are basically
if your load balancer is slow for some
reason and every request is going
through it that can become a huge
performance bottleneck and then
additionally it
obviously any single time you add a
component to your system it's going to
add additional complexity that you have
to think about such as you know what
happens when this component fails
but ultimately i hope this video was
helpful guys i certainly could have used
a load balancer in my life
now you guys know how to use them too